[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL BILODEAU: Good afternoon.
My name is Bill
Bilodeau, and I'm
a developer advocate at Google.
So today we're going
to talk about improving
game performance so that
you can make high fidelity
games on Android.
The first part will be
about common performance
issues and the profiling tools
you can use to find them.
Next, Jungwoo from
Samsung will be talking
about optimization techniques.
And then, finally,
we'll hear from Duke
at Netmarble about how
those techniques were
put into practice in one of
their games, "Lineage 2."
One of the best reasons for
making a high-performance game
is to have high fidelity.
When we say high
fidelity, we mean
high-quality, realistic,
immersive graphics.
High-fidelity games used
to be limited to just PCs
and consoles.
But with recent
improvements in hardware,
it's now possible to
play these types of games
on mobile devices.
Even with the latest
hardware, developers still
need to be aware of
performance issues.
Before I talk about
that, I want to discuss
some of the basic
concepts of rendering.
Rendering commands
are built on the CPU.
The graphics driver queues these
commands for the GPU to render.
Because the GPU is a
separate processor,
it runs asynchronously
with the CPU.
This means that the
CPU can build commands
for the current frame, while
the GPU renders commands
from the previous frame.
To avoid artifacts, frames are
displayed at VSync intervals.
This is every
16.67 milliseconds.
If the GPU misses a
VSync, the frame buffer
is displayed at the next VSync.
Too many missed VSyncs can
cause stuttering or janks.
If the frame is not
a multiple of VSyncs,
you can see uneven frame times.
So, for example, let's say
we have a frame time that's
about 20 milliseconds.
It will display some of
the frames every two VSyncs
and some frames every VSync.
To smooth out the frame rate,
we can delay the rendering
to make the frame time an
even VSync of intervals.
As in this case, we'll
now see the display
happening every other VSync.
One of the advantages
of doing this
is also that it
saves battery life
because you are doing less
work on the CPU and GPU.
The trade-off, of
course, is that you're
doing less rendering.
So let's look at some
of the issues that
can cause slow performance.
CPU activity can be a
cause of slow performance.
A CPU bottleneck is when a
CPU can't keep up with a GPU.
This means that the GPU is
waiting and idle, waiting
for commands to be sent to it.
This breaks the
parallelism between the CPU
and the GPU, which
makes it less efficient.
Some of the common
causes of CPU bottlenecks
include too many draw calls.
And this is because
with every draw call,
there's a certain amount of
driver overhead on the CPU.
Single threading can
also be an issue.
This is when you put
too much on one thread,
for example, rendering and game
simulation on the same thread.
Now, both of these
could be improved
with the Vulkan graphics API.
If you remember
last year at I/O,
we announced Vulkan
on Android devices.
Vulkan is a more
explicit API than OpenGL
and is closer to what the
hardware is actually doing.
This means it has less
overhead per draw call.
It can also do multithreaded
command buffers building.
So another problem that could
be causing a CPU bottleneck
is too many state
changes, and this
adds to the driver overhead.
The GPU can also be a
cause of slow performance.
GPU bottlenecks
are when the GPU is
taking too much time to render.
The driver can help this
by buffering commands
for a couple of frames, but
when this queue gets full,
the CPU has to just wait.
As with CPU bottlenecks,
this breaks the parallelism
between the CPU and the GPU.
Some of the common causes of
GPU bottlenecks are fill rate.
On modern phones, the
resolution is very high.
And this can be worse if
you have long fragmentators.
One thing you can do is render
to a lower resolution buffer.
Another problem could be high
polygon count, especially when
you have very complex geometry.
Buffer synchronization
can also be an issue.
This is when the GPU has
to wait until the CPU is
done writing to a buffer
that's shared between the two.
And also, too many
state changes.
As with CPU, too many state
changes can be a problem.
These hardware state changes
can cause the graphics hardware
to flush the pipeline,
which introduces a stall.
Overheating is a common
issue with mobile devices.
As the temperature
goes up, the system
has a governor that makes the
frequency and voltage go down.
This is called
thermal throttling.
As the SOC cools, the
frequency and the voltage
go back up again.
But then, this leads to
unstable frame rates.
Developers should not
overlook long load times.
This can cause people to
stop playing their game.
Cold loads are
when the game needs
to load assets into memory.
They may need to process assets.
For example, you may need
to decompress assets.
You also may need
to compile shaders.
This all takes time on the CPU.
You might try caching to
avoid duplicating this work
every time you load.
Battery performance
is also important.
This affects how long your
users can play the game.
Unfortunately, high-performance
games tend to use more battery.
Vulkan can also help with this
because it uses the CPU less.
This is important
because the CPU
runs at a higher clock
speed than the GPU,
so it uses more power.
To detect issues
like this, there
are several tools available.
Unfortunately, one
tool may not be enough.
For example, if you're
doing low-level profiling,
you may want to see the hardware
counters, like on the GPU.
This requires vendors
specific tools.
So the first one we'll
look at is Systrace,
and this is from Google.
Systrace is a
system trace viewer,
and it shows threads
executing on the CPU.
The longer the trace, the more
time is being spent executing.
You can use custom trace
events in your game
to see how different
sections of the game take,
how long they take.
This can also show you
how much concurrency
there is within your game.
One thing you can
do with Systrace
is see system activity
relative to your game
and see potential dependencies
that could be causing things
to run slow.
For more information, you
should watch this session that
was presented earlier
at I/O, and we have
it recorded on the I/O website.
Simpleperf is a CPU
profiler from Google.
It shows the percentages
of time spent
in various parts of the game.
For example, we can use it to
find the percentage of time
spent in shared libraries.
And that way, we can tell where
most of the time was spent.
We can then look at, say, one
of these shared libraries,
and then see how much
percentage of time
was spent in each
of the functions.
Now, one caveat with
Simpleperf right now
is it's not very easy to use.
It requires a certain
amount of setup,
and it's only command line.
But once you get
the hang of it, it's
actually producing some
valuable information.
Other profilers include the
hardware vendor profilers.
For example, Qualcomm has
a Snapdragon Profiler,
ARM has Streamline, and Nvidia
has the Tegra System Profiler.
Game engines also
have profilers.
For example, Unity and Unreal
have built-in profilers.
And also, there are
graphics debuggers,
like RenderDoc and
Google's GAPID.
These tools can
capture API calls
that can help you find
inefficiencies in the API.
So here's an
example of profiling
a game using the Qualcomm
Snapdragon profiler.
Let's see if we can find
out where the bottleneck is.
It shows CPU traces
similar to Systrace,
and it also shows GPU traces.
So on the lower part
of this display here,
we can see the CPU
scheduling with colors
corresponding to each thread.
On the upper part
is the GPU activity,
where the blue bars represent
when the GPU is rendering.
Now, the first thing
we'll notice here
is that the GPU was
idle for a long time.
That's bad.
In contrast, the CPU core 1
is busy almost the whole time.
This is a classic case
of a CPU bottleneck.
Now, we might be able
to multithread this,
but in this case, this
is the render thread.
In OpenGL, you can't do
multithreaded rendering.
So let's take a closer
look at what's going on
by doing a frame capture.
Now, frame capture shows us the
API call similar to debuggers
like RenderDoc.
And if we look at
the frame capture,
if we look at the
draw calls, there's
a lot of draw calls
going on here.
almost 1,500 draw calls.
That's actually a lot,
too much for a mobile CPU.
Now, remember, with every draw
call, there's CPU overhead.
And that all adds up.
So one thing we can do
is we can draw less,
or we can batch these
draw calls together
by the ones that have the same
materials, batch them together,
and then you will have
fewer draw calls which
will improve performance.
Our next speaker is Jungwoo Kim,
and he is a principal engineer
at Samsung.
He will talk about
game optimizations.
[APPLAUSE]
JUNGWOO KIM: Thank you, Bill.
I'm Jungwoo Kim.
I'm managing GPU driver,
graphics performance for Galaxy
product, and also rating Khronos
standard and game [? job ?]
[? tag ?] in Samsung
Mobile division.
So I will talk
about what should be
the right direction
of gaming optimization
and also some bad practices
from our real experiences.
I think you all know that
Samsung is a good phone maker,
but you may not know about
we are working with many game
developers for improving
[INAUDIBLE] system entirely.
[? It's sad. ?] So we are
working with over 50 game
studios and developers with
around the 30 game titles, too.
with various kind of ways
under our new game developer
support program, Galaxy
GameDev, from March last year.
And thank you, partners.
I also strongly appreciate my
team in Suwon HQ, in the UK,
US, and Ukraine to
support partners
with endless overnight
work with many beers.
During our supporting
game developers,
we also have a
question about what
would be the real goal
of gaming optimization.
Just keeping stable frames per
second like this smile mark?
But it looks like it's getting
boring by frame by frame
and doesn't look
like it will bring
high fidelity to any games.
Like this, quality
level also would
be another point we
have to take care,
the resolutions in
complexity and more
visual intensive graphics.
The games will have more rich
content with better quality,
and this can make
games fun to play.
But traditional
optimization is just
traded off between quality
and performance, always.
If we want to get more
frames per second,
then we should
expect less quality.
Low content quality is
the reason of boring.
Users will leave easily,
even the game is still
keeping 60 frame per second.
Some graphics
extensions will give you
a way to manage both
quality and performance,
but it works only with
some corner cases.
How we can make this?
This is even a year ago.
Vulkan demo [INAUDIBLE]
what we showed to you
during our S7
[? unpack. ?] Now, how
can we chase both
quality and performance
at the same time with
more general use cases?
I want to show one simple
example from [? the address ?]
[? side ?] because
we are phone maker.
The thermal throttling is
one of the critical problems
of phone makers like us.
And Samsung has a good
structure of managing therma.
From AP chipset, but it's stuck
in a certain level nowadays.
So we optimize the structure
of a heat spreader and changing
interface material has a nine
times better conductivity
between a heat spreader
and AP chipset.
So now, Galaxy 8 has seven
[INAUDIBLE] AP chipset
[INAUDIBLE] in
worst case scenario,
and this gives more
comfortable experience to user
when they play games.
This is not just trade-off
but making fundamental changes
to big breakthrough jump.
Then how we can
do similar things
with softer side,
not harder side,
chasing both quality
and performance?
We strongly believe the
answer should be Vulkan.
Vulkan is open standard
cross platform,
new generation graphics
API from Khronos Group.
It's really thin, lightweight,
predictable, portable,
and cacheable.
It supports [? predictable ?]
explicit control
and delivers a bunch of great
tools to optimize your games.
We have many times faced
at [? nothing ?] [? do ?]
[? more ?] situation except
dropping quality with old API
GL ES.
OpenGL ES is easy to use and
can make quick prototyping,
so it's still usable
for some use cases.
But we believe that Vulkan
is breakthrough jump
like I showed to you with the
hardware example and softer
side.
First, lower CPU overhead.
Vulkan is a thin structure,
so driver can have
very small overhead in CPU.
The over 100 draw calls can
easily spend some milliseconds
with the GL ES,
but Vulkan doesn't.
This will give you some
margin on resources,
and you can use this
for your own purposes
like better performance
or longer battery life.
We implemented many
[INAUDIBLE] Vulkan samples
to prove Vulkan is a really good
thing to our marketing team.
You may not even
imagine how many samples
we implemented
before S7 launched
for convincing internal people.
This is a regular
demo, which one
sample which our team developed
for around September 2015.
You can see left side Vulkan
uses similar or less CPU
but renders almost double
or more frames per second
than GL ES.
You may think this is just a
demo sample or a corner case,
but Vulkan works with
the real games, too.
Here is "Vainglory."
We have been working with Super
Evil Megacorp since April 2016.
You can see the
right side of Vulkan
shows much stable frame per
second without big frame drops.
We see around a 20%
performance gain,
near 60 frame per second in
even throttling situation
with the Galaxy S7.
Second, explicit control.
You can manage precise
command buffer submits
from one of each render place
or one for some groups of render
places.
You also can change dependence
between each pipeline stage
with the pipeline
barrier function.
If you give barrier between
fragment to [? vertex ?] stage,
then every
[? vertex ?] stage will
wait until finishing
previous fragment stage.
If you change barrier
between every frame stage,
fragment stage, then there will
be no waiting between fragment
to [? vertex ?] stage anymore.
You also can manage the
memory more precisely.
You can use different memory
time for each performance.
And this will give you more
optimal memory management.
So this is the [? DS-5 ?]
[? Streamline ?] capture
of a certain game
we are working with.
First capture shows
original GL ES.
And there are wide gaps between
each render places coming
from CPU overhead of some 100
draw calls for each render
pass.
12 milliseconds for GPU
processing is required.
Even after we port
everything with Vulkan
but can [? cease ?]
capture number two,
worst performance,
like 24 millisecond.
This comes from using
wrong pipeline barrier.
Then, number three is now
showing the pipeline barrier,
and then this takes
just 12 milliseconds.
Third, uniform.
Uniform is one of the critical
parts of graphics programming.
This has a basic
intention of interaction
between CPU and GPU.
So it can give
quite a big impact
to performance in many cases.
But you can manage
uniform buffer in Vulkan
to get less or
better performance.
We've developed four different
incremental implementations
from [? brute ?] [? force ?] to
either condition of [INAUDIBLE]
opposite way.
And you can see the
performance difference
is from the one frame per second
to the 43 frames per second.
Let's see the video clips from
our 1,250 draw calls sample.
Implementation like this,
Vulkan gives you the ability
to control things precisely.
But you may also feel
it is hard to handle.
But you don't have to
worry about being handled
by yourself, all the things
with Vulkan implementation,
but the game engine
supports now Vulkan.
We worked with Epic
Games from May 2015
for the UE 4's
Vulkan supporting.
They released 4.12 as
first Vulkan RHI for UE 4
and recent release
Vulkan support is now
getting better and better.
We've work with Unity for
supporting Vulkan in Unity 5
since September 2016, and
5.6 was released recently
at the first official Vulkan
render support Unity version.
To wrap up, we believe
Vulkan is the answer
for chasing both quality
and performance to develop
high-fidelity games on
Android from many experiences
with our partner game
companies and developers.
It can give more performance,
longer battery life, less heat
problem, more visual
quality to your game.
A little bit complicated,
but still, game engine
will help you can use it even
without any understanding
of Vulkan implementation.
One more thing,
Vulkan will help more
with mass mainstream devices.
We tested with one
of Vulkan's games
with both Galaxy S7
and A5 2017 model
and see more performance
gain with the Galaxy A5.
Even Flagship shows
better performance,
but Vulkan will boost
more with mass product.
So Vulkan is not only a
Flagship feature anymore.
We are all ready to develop
high-fidelity gaming.
Android devices, technologies,
platforms are all set up.
I want to introduce Duke to
introduce about the "Lineage 2
Revolution" case study.
[APPLAUSE]
DUKE DONGHYUN KIM: Thank you.
Yeah, developing
"Lineage 2" [INAUDIBLE]
on the mobile as launched.
My name is Duke.
I'm a VP of Marketing
Intelligence in mobile.
And I'm here to introduce
"Lineage 2 Revolution"
and to share Samsung and
Google, and then mobile
[? core working, ?] what kind
of [? digital ?] [INAUDIBLE] we
made with you.
Last year, I did a
show speech like this,
and that was a part
of my bad memory.
So at this time, not to make
that kind of thing again,
this time I prepared
many video clips
so that we will
not make you bored.
So before talking, I want to
show you a very short clip
of "Lineage 2."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
DUKE DONGHYUN KIM: Yup.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, one thing I want
to tell you is this
is the actual game play video
on a mobile device, maybe
Samsung S7, maybe.
I think our title could be
called a high-performance game
by graphic quality, at least.
But to my boss, the
most important thing
may be that high
performance means high KPI.
So I want to share what kind of
KPI we are achieving in Korea.
Yup.
Record-breaking success.
"Lineage Revolution"
was a huge success.
Just 30 days after
launch, this title
achieved over US $176
million only in South Korea.
We just opened the
title in South Korea.
It took us only 17 days
to earn US $100 million,
and a huge [? base ?] five
million monthly active users.
That is the same amount as 10%
of the South Korea population.
Every number is recording
in South Korea mobile gaming
industry.
And it recorded over two
million daily active users.
We do our best to
keep this number.
Because "Lineage 2
Revolution" is MMORPG,
the max number of concurrent
users is very, very important.
And it records 740,000 five
weeks later after launch.
It's a huge amount of people.
Finally, according to
SuperData Research,
"Lineage 2 Revolution"
was the number one title
in global mobile
market in February.
Only in February, just one
month, but we are proud of it.
As I said, we just opened
this title only in Korea,
and the Korean mobile market
is not small but not big.
What I want to say is,
number one in Korea
doesn't mean one in global.
But February, we make that.
To make this kind
of result, when
we planned to
develop this title,
we had three major
goals to make it to be
the next [? global ?] title.
The first thing is [INAUDIBLE]
console graphic quality.
We just want to take [INAUDIBLE]
graphics [INAUDIBLE].
The second thing is vast,
open world environment.
In Korea, before
"Lineage Revolution,"
[INAUDIBLE] was an action RPG.
And action RPG means every
user tried every stage
for enjoying game, and that
then made many people bored.
So we thought open world
would be an answer for that.
And massive castle sieges.
Massive castle sieges
is very important.
Why that is important is to
extend our title lifespan,
making new content
is not enough.
It takes too much time.
It takes too much money.
So to extend our lifespan,
the most important thing
is making user build their
community based on our content.
That content is castle sieges.
I want to show you two clips.
One clip is introduction
clip, and the other
is actual game play video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
DUKE DONGHYUN KIM: Yeah, this
is the introduction video
of castle sieges mode.
The one thing I
want to tell you is,
to enjoy this kind
of a good content,
every user have to make--
build their own clan,
and they have to discuss
about how to win,
how to beat the others.
And that means,
to enjoy this one,
the users have to make it
from their own community.
So this is actual play video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Next slide, please.
[END PLAYBACK]
OK.
Yep, it's awesome.
You can enjoy this
kind of content
on your mobile phone, real-time
battle with up to 200 players.
But that is not easy.
There are so many
problems we had to solve.
Something like the
stable frame rate
and the [INAUDIBLE] problem,
and the battery problem, as Bill
said earlier.
So how to make it a [INAUDIBLE]?
We thought Vulkan can
be one of our solutions.
So we expected, with Vulkan,
we can solve the frame rate
problem and also,
our battery problems.
So this is an actual example.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
The upside is using Vulkan.
The downside is
just using OpenGL.
You can check the frame rate.
The Vulkan version
is more stable.
[END PLAYBACK]
This is another example.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
DUKE DONGHYUN KIM: And because
the frame rate is more stable,
we can add more effect.
This is the original version
of "Lineage 2 Revolution."
This is using OpenGL.
You can see very clear screen.
And we add depth
of field effect.
That makes user the feel
depths of the environment.
So we chose to get
started, and we have teams
throughout graphics to
maintain our position in Korea.
And we plan to launch
this title outside Korea.
And then you can enjoy this
content maybe in this year.
That means we have to
make our title [INAUDIBLE]
and device reader
keeping our edge.
And we believe we can
do that with Vulkan.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]